l'un étape qu'on a utilisé l a reposé
sans grande surprise sur trois éléments
trois ingrédients la concertation avec
toutes les parties prenantes bivouac a
démis au niveau départemental au niveau
local deux des choses c'est que vous le
savez le des continents pour ce qui
concerne les écoles repose sur ce cadre
tout à fait indiscutable qui est le
respect du cadre sanitaire c'est la
condition sinequanone de la reprise
évidemment on tient compte des des des
spécificités de chacun ça n'est pas la
même chose de faire le des confits
demandant une petite école rurale qui a
trois ou quatre classes que dans une
école qui a 30 une trentaine de classes
possiblement de beaucoup plus nombreux
enseignants présents pour les
collectivités locales ça n'est pas la
même chose ça ne sont pas les mêmes
contraintes
le cadre est indiscutable mais vraiment
cette concertation et d'applications
ceux qui nous ont amenés à faire un
travail tout en finesse avec les
différents les différents acteurs